as I as my brief chat with Jesus it's
like after he started his own lab in
Ching hua he's already made some great
discoveries in his own lab let's welcome
Gaeseong back and deliver the last hug
of the symposium thanks for the
introduction is also my great honor to
present the work developing our own life
and today I would like to share with you
a story which might shine a little light
on how the memory trees is formed in the
mammalian codex so as we all know that
human as the most intelligent creature
on earth have the biggest bring relative
to its body size and the neocortex is so
large that it come it is believed that
contain a lot of long-term memories and
it is the long-term memory that allow us
to send since the environment to make
imagination to make creation to do a lot
of high functions however how this
long-term memory traces is formed in the
mummy cortex up to now is still unclear
but it is not totally unclear process
this star is mainly on by hm by starting
the patient of HM character by
researchers in MIT and also on some
non-human patients non-human primates
sorry
reveal that this process of memory
formation and model about to stage
memory system so memory are sort to be
stored in the hippocampus very quickly
and then through a very slow process of
system consolidation it's gradually
formed in the core core modules and this
process has been proved in a lot of
studies however to really review such
process and really know how the bring is
a calling the memory need new techniques
to trace the formation process of
individual neurons so we need a method
to screen large population of Kalkin
earrings and also we need this
measurement be in the single cellular
resolution and also this recording
should be very long term in order to
trace the whole process of long-term
memory formation now there are two class
of analysis many exist one is so-called
online analysis people developed genetic
coded calcium sensitive dies and voltage
sensitive dies to review the events of
spikes in neurons that response in
milliseconds or tens of milliseconds and
it can review simultaneously hungries
2000 mineral however for larger volume
of the cortex this technique is hard to
recall course now the imaging technique
cannot image so a very large big volume
of the cortex and another strategy is
the so-called offline NASA's so people
utilize the advantage
of ameliorating so the immediate early
genes the class of gene that we
activated by the neural activation like
spikes and those activation can reflect
in the expression of the genes in
minutes to hours and we have been shown
to be very closely related to the
behavior like memory and memory recall
and it's very easy to recording a very
large scale so a lot of a lot of people
have take efforts in this process and
the sea force reporter and arc reporter
have been generated today I would like
to talk another reporter called ziff 268
it's also called egr1 so this reporter
we could see using the in vivo
two-photon imaging in the quad core
areas and you can see in a three hundred
micro meter diameter volume we will
review around three to five thousand
neurons simultaneously from layer 1
through layer 5 and if you closely look
at them the expression intensity of the
reporter actually distribute variant Lee
from layer 1 through layer 6 and this
might represent the activity difference
in different layers and if you look at
the brain slice and you could very
detail that different cortical areas
have the different activity according to
that and those active signals are
actually try driven by in your activity
and if we measure the expression of egfp
signal the reporter signal since
sighs raped according to the dynamics we
can get a sense of about one hour delay
for the expression of one stimuli
induced signal and this signal seems to
be very sharp so that you have a
relatively high temporal resolution so
with this method we could measure the
living mice for three months and in the
first year when we developed this method
my students quantify the GFP signal for
each individual cell by hand however
this process is too painful and a lot of
them give up immediately because each
volume we need to quantify 3,000 and
each condition each mice we will qualify
about six volumes and each condition
each condition we will consist about 24
times measuring so it's a huge number of
quantification so we spent another year
to the vet automatic segregation system
to using the computer to segregate those
identify those signals so that we can
detect the neurons according to its
shape but not with intensity then this
segregated signals can be a plot in the
digitized manner to start to trace the
changes caused by particular memory
formation and this method obviously have
some pros and cons compared to other
media origin mediate method this is much
brighter signals allow the tracing of
almost eighty percent campaigns to post
in neurons within a volume and it's also
showing very great activity-dependent
expression
and each r 1 is sort it is already being
shown to be related to the maintenance
of long-term synaptic potentiation and
also the long-term memory however it
have very high background so even in the
naive States a lot of sales shows year p
so you cannot tell whether new wrong is
activated during the task just according
to its brightness also its expression
may have some effect of cell types of
ethnicity so in order to balance that we
need to do a cell by cell based
calibration before and after the
training and get the whole idea how this
signal dynamics can reflect the neural
activity within the core pahlavi and
this is what we saw so we use the
contextual fear memory paradigm to form
the contextual fear of one mind in
within one mice in the week image the
GFP signal when the mouse is receiving
the contacts eight training and test
another one put the mouse in the other
contacts and image the same signal and
we can see that on the reporter show
different different activation in
separate nearing symbols although there
are some neurons that show common
activation and within the same paradigm
if we compare two diff to same context
then the neurons appear to be similar
activated so this allow us to compare
different contacts induced responses in
the cortex and this is what we really
see from layer 1 through layer 5 and
what you
so here is a 3d reconstruction of the
confocal imaging on the right and on the
left it's a real imaging and this
imaging is the composed of three pseudo
kada pizzuto color the red one indicated
a reporter in ten seeing the home k
trial green one composed the signal in
the context a trial and the blue one is
the signal in the context C trial and
you can immediately see that in the lair
to their very great separations of three
different contacts well when the signal
goes down in the lair fall you see a lot
of signals merge together so that
different layers may have different
responses to a formed memory and for the
black ones it's the vessel which do not
express egr1 and the dots are actually
the apical dendrites or collector
dendrites so that we actually saw that a
signals in a layer 2 so very great
separation while signaling layer 3 and
therefore seems to be merged together
this make us a little bit a little bit
confused because we know that the rear
cortex is actually very specific for
different doom lies in different context
the context a and context see the stem
lie our changing so much why the act
with the same population of neurons and
if we reconsider the contacts so what
contact me is a temporal spatial
combination of different components of
the stimuli and we think
it's because the thing we saw here for
the mixed signal actually reflects the
the temporal accumulation of different
components induced response for example
on time one the mouse is looking at the
background or an time to is concentrate
on one door or some other place so
different part of the neurons might
activate it and to respond specifically
in the deep layers well this makes
different contexts seems to be similar
build to the temporal accumulation
effect well if there is a neuron that
continuously response to the environment
to the specific context no matter what
the component it looks then it will
respond specifically to this context
formed invariant presentation we want to
evaluate this hypothesis so if this is
true then if we use the signal in one
context to minus the signal in another
context we might see very little changes
in the layer three but we expect to see
strong changes in layer 2 and this is
what we saw most of neurons actually in
this whole volume do not change much and
the there consists about 3000 neurons
and most of them from the signal changes
formed Gaussian distribution well the
the there's a heavy tail portion of the
signals that show higher activation
levels and those neurons mainly
localized in layer 2 and if we qualify
all the cortical areas we measured at
really most coracle areas in response to
different contexts show the similar
distribution that only the layer to the
superficial layer of the volume showed
very strong separation of the signals
while in the deep layers the signal
changes of the EGR 1jp reporter dinner
show too much hinge and this is
consistent with the idea that's the
contact related memories may get really
manly in superficial layers and to
further demonstrate this we also use
this simple of simplifies to malign so
we anesthetize the mice and then use led
to generate synchro stimulus on the real
system and in this control experiment we
can see the activation of neurons it
throughout the quad core volume from
layer 42 layer 2 so this tell us
actually the Lear the little changes in
layer 3 and therefore in free moving
life as you to the temporal accumulation
effect so the layer to neural show the
invariant presentation then we want to
see whether this presentation is
actually a memory like response we found
the answer is yes because those neural
the response in those neurons actually
are activated gradually through about
two weeks and the signal when the mouse
experience the same context increase
gradually and until about 15 days and
then it lasts very long time until one
month later the response is still very
high while in the volume average the
signal in the
volume do not see so much changes and
also the we found that the signal in the
layer two neurons also show a stringent
linear correlation with the recall of
the contextual fear the mouse freeze
amount is nearly correlate with the
signal and also different context can
fund different population of new
examples show very discrimination are
English populations in response to
different context also this memory
related signals can last for as long as
three months and the different areas
seems to have different dynamics for
this context specific response the rural
areas decayed a little bit while the
rituals panel area last for very long
time and this signal or sing in
different cortical areas like motor
cortex Vehicle Act and this semental
sensory cortex and it might imply that
the memory traces is widely distributed
across different cortical areas so in a
brief summary on we using the EGR one
reporter we saw the contextual fear
memory related cells mainly located in
layer 2 while in layer 3 therefore dear
me represent variables doom like
contents and the context is actually the
special temporal spatial combination of
the layer of the different components so
it's very simple ideas whether this
combination of the layer 34 activities
can contribute to the invariant
presentation in layer 2 so 2
I further ask this question to
demonstrate the question we did further
analysis and that a very short answer is
maybe yes we use the learning induced
signals to quantify the late layer for
neurons and also we use these signals to
generate a pattern which may mimic the
synapse strength between the layer 2 and
layer for neurons and if the formed
memory connections is steady then we can
use this synaptic connection to predict
the signals between layer 2 and the
layer 4 and it should be a linear
correlation between them and yes we
found that this meaning a correlation
and before the memory before the
training we also saw a little bit
meaning a correlation however the r
square is learning to be lower and also
you can also see that the slope is lower
means the strengths between the layers
for and the layer two neurons
specifically are two neurons are a
little bit lower than expected so
learning may strengthen this process and
this process the strengthening during
the memory consolidation is cheap can be
dependent because if we leash lesion the
hippocampus we found that this increase
is totally abolished and this is true
for all mice we have measured we can
also use our system to see the system
consolidation in vehicle hacks so in the
system consolidation the quick memory is
formed in the hippocampus and it will
gradually
remodel the cortical connection so an
implication is that you may see
differential recall in views responses
for recent and the remote time and
whether we can see it the answer is yes
in de for when we recall a contextual
fear response it's um accurate this
neuron however two weeks later if we
look at the same memory record husk it
activate different population of neurons
and this steady presentation can last
for one month and we can see the same
population is activated and if we can't
fight then we can see separated neural
populations in a recent recall
populations response fast and then okay
in a later phase its last longer and
this separations also hit can be
dependent because when the hip temper is
a lesion we saw the abolishment of this
representation changes the recoiling
bills the steady presentation throughout
two weeks and you show the significance
more overlapping of the active in Europe
and this is not due to the sensation
defect because the activity neurons also
different from the homepage ones so to
conclude our discovery we found that
context specific neurons are formed in
cortical layer 2 in the context specific
response is going through a process of
is formed through a process of
consolidation and also hip tempers is
required for both the correlation
increase between their key players and
therefore are there too and also
is required for the so-called system
consolidation process and this works
many but done by doctors here who is
also in audience here and I think and
support from my from the way that allow
me to bring the EGR one reporter to
Ching hua and quickly start our
experiment and thank you for your
attention so I'm a little confused
because in the mouse the input from the
geniculate comes in to layer 4 and the
bottom of layer 23 so that's the input
that is always going to be driven by
different things yes yes and and I by
your idea that that layer two cells may
may have already established through
learning you know a specific
connectivity but the output from the
cortex is really from layer 4 I mean
layer 5 and six and one would expect
since they have to direct specific
instructions to different parts that
they should have some specificity in
terms of what they extract as well and
you don't your data doesn't show
anything down does so in there deep
layers of layer 5 I think layer 5 can
also be divided to layer 5 a and the
layer 5 B and recently poor have also
shown that layer 5 am i also received
same as input however
in our study the signal is kind of low
because we haven't used a higher power
to trace those changes and we mainly
focus on there for through layer two
neurons so in our study we haven't
touched their five in systematic way so
I couldn't answer your question now but
we would like to look also look at that
quick questions yeah I very like your
computational model very nice color
picture and differentials in a staining
one quick question is that you know in
your lesion study you focus on the hippo
Campos you know formation areas and your
model you know to stop live is the
contextual fear and I believe you know a
michael i should be more and also i
don't know much about the antiviral
system in the mouse but the smelling
scents the offertory input is very
strong i wonder whether you know in your
legs setting try to listen the you know
amygdaloid input and output and also the
you know auditory input to neuron and
see how it might modify in other
activity laughs where different areas
okay thank you for your questions so for
the fear conditioning actually the
cutest fear conditioning is mainly
involved in the amygdala and the
contextual fear our hip temper is also
involved and there's a lot of started
have been clearly showing that and
actually we also found that if you
lesion the hippocampus the contextual
fear responses for the long-term
component is pretty much abolished so we
are sure that hippocampal is involved in
this process secondly the amygdala
definitely because it's a center for the
fear and it's so cool have been shown to
be involved in the memory formation so
we are also interesting how those mega
circulates in volume is the last quick
thing is when you do the two-photon you
no imagery measurement and you know one
thing we may need to have a better
control present I you know the servo
circulation but fro to that patty
regions you know the remember will bring
you know the neuron they live along the
water shades and determine by the you
know blood circulation distributions you
know and I believe the change of the
server but for a different region may
have a partial contributions to the
differential activity of the neurons at
different layers that could serve a
consideration for some confounding if
that is the case we might expect to see
try to try out differences because the
changes think that but actually our
system is quite sustained I mean
consistent in this case report so we did
consider this as maybe factor changing
our recording systems but we measure
that yep thank you um I might have
missed this but um so you showed that
the layer to when you put the mouse in a
context and then change the context
there wasn't much overlap between the
activated cells why don't you just did
the simple test of putting the mouse
back in the same context and seeing the
amount of overlap or reactivation yes I
I need to show that yeah so the contacts
thus being the same contacts the same
population of neurons could be activated
but if you look at the consolidation
process it's only after the system
consolidation that happen they are very
strictly in one population but before
that is still in
a systematic you would eval a evolution